[Aplausos]
[Música]
hola a todos que tal cansaditos ya no
bueno
antes de comunicar osm irrevocable
decisiones y cuando digo irrevocable es
irrevocable
me gustaría explicaros un poquito por
encima el por qué la he tomado para que
me entendáis os pongo en antecedentes
todo comenzó un 1 de agosto día que
recibió un whatsapp de david pla un
antiguo profesor mío de la universidad
del que hacía mucho tiempo que no sabía
nada pero del que guardo muy buen
recuerdo menudas fiestas del borrego nos
pegábamos tu recuerdo una que acabamos
todos
bueno el caso es que david lo que quería
era que quedáramos esta tarde hacernos
algo yo me dije mira este quiere hacer
un remember como el pobre chaval al ser
profesor pues solo tiene dos meses y
medio de vacaciones la criatura
pues quiere exprimirlas al máximo lo
único que pasa es que llamadme sutil
pero cuando vi que se pedía una
coca-cola zero se me vino todo un poco
abajo no creo yo que las bacanales
romanas empezarán con el césar pidiendo
una coca-cola zero y en efecto lo que la
vida quería proponerme era que
aprovechando el verano y mis vacaciones
me leyera once charlas de diferentes
temáticas y después hiciese y otra
basándome en todas ellas y enrique
hombre por fin un plan cojonudo para
vacaciones tanto viaje ibiza y tanta
comida ahora en la playa y tanta basura
ahí a leer charlas como un jabato sigue
nada le dije que me las enviara y oye
genial fantástico a los dos días me
llamaron mis colegas y oscar hoy tarde o
en alicante y otro que dices que tarde o
ni que tarde o que estoy aquí leyendo
sobre la tecnología leds
rogerio de ternera ningún sitio donde se
ponga la tecnología led que se quite
todo
por favor y hablando un poquito en serio
a ver a los oradores aquí a ver si
elegimos temitas pues un poquito más
interesante de no sé por ejemplo el
pepino en el gin tónic eres culo
no se cause cosas así y eso
que tengo que decir que cuando leí el
listado de temáticas me emocioné porque
empecé a leer te quiero te digo bien
el poliamor relaciones abiertas bien
alta sensibilidad bien
pornografía muy bien
somos lo que nos comemos vamos
lo que pasa es que con esta última me
llevé un poco de chasco si resulta que
héctor climent aquí habla sobre la buena
nutrición oye que está muy bien tenemos
que evitar el creciente sobrepeso que
estamos sufriendo que como diría del
bosque poca broma con eso el sobrepeso
es un problema muy gordo de la sociedad
vamos que es una cuestión gruesa que me
entendéis un tema embarazoso
el de alta sensibilidad tampoco fue lo
que yo me esperaba llamadme raro pero al
estar situado entre poliamor y
pornografía yo creía que era otra cosa
pero no resulta que alta sensibilidad
habla sobre la sensibilidad de las
personas no lo podéis creer
pero tengo que decir que clara ortiz me
ayudó muchísimo sí como hablaba de la
sensibilidad pues siempre me lo dejaba
para leer en mi momento más sensible del
día la siesta y oye funcionó vaya que sí
funcionó tarde mes y medio leerme cinco
folios
veis en cambio el poliamor sí que fue lo
que yo creía y tengo que decir que no
puedo estar más de acuerdo con miguel
vagalume bueno de hecho en cuanto acabe
de leerla me fui a enseñárselo a mi
mujer
y la convencí para que probáramos así
que me fui corriendo a buscar a una
vecina que tengo en la finca
que además se llama igual que mi comida
favorita sushi
y aceptó así que me volví y le dije
cariño vamos a practicar poliamor e
intercambio de parejas con sus y la del
cuarto y me dijo su sí pero si es viuda
hija pues ahora yo ya se lo he dicho es
mala suerte
no le sentó muy bien no empezó a decirme
tú siempre estás igual tú siempre con
tus trucos y él dice nada de trucos que
como dice alejandro rodríguez esto no es
magia es logística
también quise poner en práctica lo que
nos dice nuria domenech bueno si dar
abrazos y decir te quiero aumenta la
autoestima y reduce el estrés pues habrá
que probarlo no así que estaba ahí un
día en la playa y vi pasar a una alemana
rubia con ojos azules en topless y me
dije es el momento de empezar y me fui
corriendo y le dio un abrazo así
sostenido como dice ella
mano de santo un subidón de autoestima
que tuve ahí arriba que se fue el
autoestima no la había visto yo la
autoestima así en años y el estrés
también me lo redujo pero de la
que me campo la tía
me pasé cuatro días que solo veía que
luces led por ahí
a la que me dejó mal cuerpo fuera de
ismael lópez y la pornografía golpes
abusos enfermedades drogas no david no
son las fiestas del borrego estoy
hablando yo de otra cosa
vaya tela qué mal rollo yo la verdad es
que no he visto nunca porno ni conozco
el mundo ni nada que tenga que ver pero
no tenía ni idea qué amarna miller a
polonia y love habían pasado por
todo eso pobrecitas tú
pero si ha habido alguien que me ha
cambiado la vida es ácido mariola olcina
y lo hizo con esta frase en la
comunicación la información se
jerarquiza lo que aparece primero es más
importante que lo que aparece segundo
por claro que se así que he cambiado
radicalmente mi manera de hablar ahora
entro en un restaurante y digo entrecot
poco hecho y ramón bilbao tiene mesa
para dos buenas tardes
y cuando llego a casa digo el mando de
la tele que el madrid juega hoy hola
hijos cómo estáis lo importante primero
sí señor
pero aparte de cambiar mi manera de
hablar
mariola ha resuelto el misterio más
enigmático de toda la humanidad porque
el maestro yoda hablaba tan raro y no es
que hablara raro es que era un pionero
de la comunicación el tío mariola donde
estas gracias y que la fuerza te
acompañe
ahora bien el chas caso más grande me lo
llevé con pablo ortiz de zárate
cuando cogí la suya cometí el error de
darle un vistazo así por encima y leí
varios nombres rubens rembrandt manet
bangkok y me dice anda la alineación de
holanda del 74 por fin una interesante a
ver qué dice de cruise a ver pero nada
falsa alarma bueno por no hablar del
figura de pepe crespo que me cojo la
suyo y empiezo a leer es la española una
aceituna como ninguna la masía aceite
puro de oliva que dio que dio la
alcoyana y digo que es anuncios nada más
empezar la charla que es la película de
antena 3 del mediodía o qué pasa sólo me
faltó volvemos en siete minutos a hombre
en resumen que después de pasarme los
últimos meses incluidas mis vacaciones
leyendo charlas de lo más interesantes
resulta que voy por ahí por la calle
contando luces led como si estuviera
loco mi mujer quiere hacer un trío con
su profesor de gimnasio ya no llamo
gordo porque al gordo de mi trabajo he
dejado de ver porno vamos una maravilla
y por lo tanto y volviendo al principio
mi decisión irrevocable a tu propuesta
david es que dadas las circunstancias de
tu solicitud resuelvo declinarla en su
totalidad no sin antes agradecer que tu
confianza aunque después de leer de leer
a cristina carretero y su hablando más
claro la he cambiado por qué lo haga tu
tía la mora
así que esta charla es para deciros que
no hago la charla
aunque si hago una charla para decir que
no hago la charla y ha hecho la charla
por lo tanto si hago la charla la madre
que lo parió al david este es que ya me
ha vuelto a liar es que toda la vida
igual bien recuerdo una vez en unas
paellas acabamos los dos con los
pantalones de buscar
mirad sabéis que os digo cerveza fría al
bar una voy a hacerme os espero
[Aplausos]
[Música]